beau temps donc à la courneuve à la
courneuve tout à l'heure un immense
concert cent cinquante mille personnes
sont attendues
un concert du chanteur sans frontières
un concert dont le bénéfice ira aux
victimes de la famine en ethiopie le
spectacle débute dans moins d'une heure
alors il n'est pas trop tard pour y
aller et henri bodiguel vous êtes sur
place j'imagine qu'il ya déjà beaucoup
de monde il ya déjà effectivement
beaucoup de monde pour ce maxi concerts
organisés sur un thème on ne peut plus
généreux puisqu'il s'agit vous l'avez
dit de la faim d'ethiopie et d'une façon
beaucoup plus générale d'ailleurs de la
faim dans le monde plus de 70 artistes d
en citer un seul ce serait forcément on
oublié parce qu'il n'est pas possible de
les citer tous il n'est pas possible de
les mentionner tous mais soixante dix
artistes vont se réunir effectivement à
partir de 14h alors la fête n'est pas
encore à proprement parler commencer il
est encore un peu trop tôt mais on
pourra quand même se poser la question
antoine di zazzo pourquoi avoir attendu
trois mois après le maxi concert de
wembley pour avoir organisé la même
chose en france
en fait nous avons été un petit peu
surpris par le concert de wembley celui
de philadelphie et lorsque nous l'avons
su début du mois de juillet pour nous il
était pratiquement impossible
d'organiser un concert pour le 13
juillet puisque c'est la veille du 14
juillet et comme vous le savez la veille
le 14 juillet tous les bals populaires
ont lieu en france et les musiciens sont
pris par ces balles donc impossible de
le réunir à cette date là quels ont été
les problèmes que vous avez pu
rencontrer afin de réunir autant
d'artistes les grands problèmes ont été
surtout technique d'imaginer une scène
où 70 artistes pouvaient se produire au
point de vue des artistes tous ont
répondu avec énormément de chaleur
énormément d'enthousiasmé à notre cause
et donc il n'y a pas eu de problème
majeur
le fait d'avoir réuni soixante dix
artistes et déjà un tour de force
évidemment comment avez-vous équilibrer
le spectacle entre 14h et puis la fin de
l'après-midi la fin même la soirée aussi
donc il va y avoir 28 passage qui vont
être à peu près de huit heures et qui
vont durer entre cinq et quinze minutes
et ensuite tous ceux qui n'ont pas pu
participer à ces passages chanteront
tous ensemble la chanson et c'est cette
utopie
il y aura des particularité puisqu'il ya
beaucoup de duos à spontanée tels que
franz france gall avec michel daniel
balavoine ensuite jeanne mas avec berger
qu'on ne verra jamais et qu'on ne verra
plus donc c'est l'occasion unique
d'avoir un spectacle qu'on retrouvera
pas henry est ce que oui est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que le public on voit
déjà qu'il ya beaucoup de monde mais a
répondu à l'attenté des organisateurs
ils sont déjà très nombreux ils sont
effectivement déjà nombreux mais enfin
il faut penser aussi que l'état allié en
quelque sorte fait que probablement le
plus gros du public deviendra que plus
tard du reste quel est le début du
programme et ce que est ce que vous avez
conçu un programme qui permette aux gens
d'avoir envie de venir dès l'ouverture
effectivement en début de programme
l'ouverture sera faite par des artistes
de couleurs puisque ça sera manu du
gombo qui va être sur scène un quart
d'heure nous avons lu voulu leur rendre
cet hommage puisqu'ils n'ont participé à
aucune grande manifestation
internationale et tout de suite après
yves duteil ensuite dorothée qui va
enchaîner dorothée va faire un duo avec
dave daniel lavoie georges chelon
charlélie couture maxime le forestier
higelin catherine lara cristiani pour ça
c'est pour le saas est pour le début du
ces pour le début du spectacle
et pour ce qui de toute façon n'aurait
pas le n'auront pas le loisir de venir
ici à la courneuve
quelle chance et ce qu'ils auront de
participer d'avoir un aperçu du
spectacle
écoutez d'abord il faut qu'ils viennent
parce qu'à 5 heures il ya johnny
hallyday johnny hallyday ensuite france
gall eu nos frères comme un cias diane
dufresne lalanne renaud jean jacques
goldman et c'est donc il y aura un
spectacle qui va se prolonger
probablement jusqu'à 10 heures merci
henri merci donc de toutes ces
précisions et donc le mieux c'est
effectivement d'aller au concert sous ce
beau temps ça sera sûrement formidable
cet après midi à la courneuve entre les
pma temps superbe
merci